dans la science qui nous permet de
contrôler une machine naturellement
instable comme ce drone s'appelle
automatique plus généralement
lottomatica pour but de concevoir des
mécanismes qui permettent au système
dynamique de s'autogouverner aujourd'hui
je voudrais vous parler un peu plus de
ce que fait heins automaticien comme moi
et puis mettre cette explication aussi
dans le contexte plus général d'un
phénomène technologique relativement
récent qu'on appelle fréquemment
l'internet des objets alors pour
comprendre l'origine de la les principes
de l'automatique on peut retourner à la
fin du xviiie siècle lorsque l'inventeur
écossais james watt met au point une
machine à vapeur qui deviendra un des
principaux éléments permettant la
révolution industrielle au siècle
suivant cette machine utilisait une
source externe de vapeur pour alimenter
un moteur qui fait tourner ici une roue
sur mon exemple watts faisait face en
particulier au problème suivant comment
maintenir la vitesse de la roue
constante alors qu'il est très difficile
de contrôler précisément le débit
d'arrivée de vapeur dans le système en
il résout ce problème grâce à un système
révolutionnaire à l'époque et qui
consiste en fait à ajouter ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui à son système
un capteur pour mesurer la vitesse de la
roue ainsi qu'un mécanisme pour exercer
une action sur la vague d'entrée de
vapeur re bouclant ainsi le système sur
lui-même dans la machine devient alors
capable de s'autoréguler
lorsque la roue tourne un peu trop vite
le capteur le détecte et le mécanisme va
fermer
laval d'entrée de vapeur al'inverse
lorsque la roue tourne trop lentement
le mécanisme va ouvrir un peu plus laval
pour alimenter le moteur alors avec le
régulateur de watts
on a un exemple historiquement important
de ce qu'on appelle une boucle de
commandes boucle de rétroaction et ses
boucles vont toujours comprendre d'abord
un système à contrôler ici le notre
moteur et la roue ensuite un capteur
pour me virer quelque chose sur ce
système
un ou plusieurs capteurs ici la vitesse
de la roue et enfin un contrôleur qui va
utiliser là où la grandeur mesurée par
le capteur pour exercer une action
régulatrice sur le système de départ est
par exemple augmenter son efficacité sa
performance ou sa robustesse dans le
capte le régulateur de watts était
purement mécanique
aujourd'hui par contre les systèmes de
commande sont plutôt implémenter sous
forme électronique au logiciel comme sur
notre drones par exemple alors ces
systèmes de commande sont en fait
partout autour de nous même s'ils sont
souvent invisibles
il faut en fait voler nos avions il
contrôle le moteur ou le système de
freinage dans vos voitures
il régule la température dans un
building comme celui ci où le procédé
chimique dans nos de nos industries et
les systèmes électriques les réseaux
électriques sont peut-être les systèmes
réguler les plus complexes jamais
construit ici il s'agit pour le système
de commande de maintenir la fréquence du
signal électrique à 60 hertz partout
dans les réseaux interconnectés qui
peuvent couvrir des continents entiers
avec des variations tolérés sur la
fréquence extrêmement faible alors ces
exemples montrent aussi que les boucles
de commande contrôle aujourd'hui des
systèmes souvent dangereux en tout cas
dans le fonctionnement doit être
maintenu le fait que ces systèmes ne
tombe finalement que rarement en panne
est à mettre sur le compte de deux
méthodes de conception développé par les
automaticien depuis watts qui sont
extrêmement rigoureuses qui fondée sur
la logique et les mathématiques et qui
accorde surtout une place de première
importance
à la notion de fiabilité de stabilité de
robustesse des systèmes avant même
d'aller chercher à optimiser leurs
performances
aujourd'hui nous sommes peut-être à
l'aube d'une nouvelle révolution
industrielle qui promet l'émergence de
réseaux de machines automatisées dont la
complexité pourraient largement dépasser
celle des systèmes que je viens de
mentionner cette révolution est d'abord
permise par la miniaturisation et
l'intégration des capteurs et des
systèmes de communication et des
calculateurs pour prendre l'exemple de
notre drones de tout à l'heure il pèse
juste 30 g et pourtant il contient plus
de puissance de calcul qu'un ordinateur
de bureau d'il ya quelques années
il a à bord aussi tout un ensemble de
capteurs qui lui permettent de se
positionner de s'orienter dans l'espace
et un système de communication avec
lequel il se connecte aux balises que
vous voyez autour de moi pour trianguler
sa position de plus en plus nous avons
cette capacité de connecter des réseaux
de capteurs intelligents finalement de
doter notre environnement d'un véritable
système nerveux central lance à peu des
réseaux locaux ou des réseaux même à
travers internet et donc ces réseaux
vont me permettre de refermer des
boucles de commandes à des échelles
toujours plus grande pour qu'on te
construire des systèmes toujours plus
complexes en même temps il faut savoir
que les méthodes et les principes nous
permettent qui vont nous permettre
d'utiliser efficacement et de manière
responsable cette technologie sont
encore pour beaucoup aujourd'hui à
inventer alors je voudrais être un peu
plus concret et qu'on regarde ensemble
le problème d'un de contrôler un système
complexe qui dans mon exemple va être le
système de leurrer le trafic routier
disons à l'échelle d'une ville comme
montréal et c'est ainsi c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs qui est remis au goût du jour
aujourd'hui par la prolifération des
capteurs et des sources de données
alors dans ce système le système à
contrôler ici est un ensemble
extrêmement complexe constitué
essentiellement de toutes les voitures
sur le réseau routier et nous mêmes les
usagers nous faisons partie intégrante
maintenant du système ensuite comme
d'habitude on a besoin de capteurs pour
mesurer quelque chose sur ce système
alors les capteurs traditionnels sont
intégrés dans la sauce et et ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils détectent il
le passage des voitures s'y ajoutent
aujourd'hui les caméras de surveillance
et de plus en plus on a aussi des
applications qui existent ou qui vont
exister pour demander aux usagers
eux-mêmes de fournir de l'information
sur le trafic en envoyant leurs
positions et leur vitesse dans le trafic
et peut-être l'état des routes là où il
se trouve par exemple
enfin on peut imaginer ici pour cette
application que toutes ces données vont
être collectées et fusionnée à un
contrôleur un centre de calcul qui va
implémenter le contrôleur alors ces
ordinateurs vont estimer l'état du
trafic en temps réel et vont pouvoir
prendre des décisions sur la façon de
réguler le trafic de diriger les
différents flux de contrôler les feux de
circulation etc
à travers cette application cet exemple
d'application qui est en fait d'écrire
un peu de manière naïve ici on va le
voir je voudrais je voudrais mentionner
dans le reste de la période ici trois
défis qu'on doit relever pour développer
un tel système de manière un peu plus
réaliste
le premier défi on parle souvent des
gains de productivité qui pourrait être
permis par l'utilisation plus d'objets
connectés mais notre premier défi en
automatique c'est toujours de maintenir
la fiabilité et la robustesse de
systèmes de commande toujours plus grand
et complexe
on sait par l'expérience et même par la
théorie que si on va chercher uniquement
à optimiser la performance d'un système
on peut le rendre en même temps plus
fragiles et plus susceptibles à des
pannes importantes donc dans notre
système de gestion de trafic ce qui va
nous falloir faire c'est arrivé à le
concevoir de manière à pouvoir démontrer
avant qu'ils soient développés avant
qu'ils soient déployés qu'une panne
locale ou une situation imprévue
localement ne va pas aboutir à une panne
généralisée de notre système
en plus des problèmes de ce genre de
problème il faut semer il faut il faut
simple il faut regarder aujourd'hui
aussi la sécurité des systèmes de
commande qu'on met en réseau parce
qu'ils deviennent des cibles
privilégiées des attaques informatiques
alors en 2008
en particulier on a découvert un virus
qui était peut-être le premier virus à
s'attaquer à viser spécifiquement les
infrastructures physiques dans ce cas
particulier
les contrôleurs de certains moteurs
industriels
ce virus était été baptisé stuxnet ce
qu'ils faisaient c'est qu'il installait
un programme entre le contrôleur qui
implémentent et en logiciels d'une part
et puis le système physique c'est-à-dire
les moteurs avec leurs capteurs d'autre
part et ils envoyaient des commandes
erronées aux moteurs les faisant
s'emballer et en même temps il
ils envoyaient ils simulaient des
données normal des capteurs empêchant
ainsi le contrôleur de détecter qu'il y
avait un problème alors notez que cette
attaque est complètement générique elle
peut s'appliquer à n'importe quel
système de commandes y compris notre
système de gestion de trafic
une fois que les communications avec le
centre de de calcul ont été détournés
donc une des choses qui préoccupent le
plus aujourd'hui les groupes de
recherche en automatique
c'est de savoir comment améliorer
globalement la résilience de ces grands
systèmes connectés
comment détecter rapidement qu'il ya une
défaillance voire qu'une attaque est en
cours et finalement comment prouver le
plus possible qu'un système est sûre
avant de le déployer physiquement
deuxième défi maintenir la
confidentialité des données des
utilisateurs qui sont collectés par tous
ces capteurs alors le problème c'est que
les problèmes de conflits de
confidentialité sont souvent assez
difficile à appréhender 28 ivement parce
qu'en général ils sont pas dus à une
seule application particulière mais
plutôt à la possibilité de recouper
entre elles des sources de données
différentes pour revenir à mon exemple
de trafic
on sait que les po2 les données de
position qui pourrait être envoyée par
les usagers à travers leurs téléphones
cellulaires sont extrêmement difficiles
à anonymiser et en particulier retirer
des identifiants évident comme un non et
c'est d'une base de données qui contient
des positions est clairement insuffisant
alors ce qui se passe c'est que une
personne peut être identifiés avec quasi
certitude à partir de son historique des
positions et en fait même si cet
historique très approximatif il suffit
de savoir quels sont les deux ou trois
quartiers que sept personnes fréquentent
le plus ça va correspondre au quartier
où cette personne habite là où elle
travaille
et peut-être là où elle fait ses courses
et aujourd'hui ces informations sur
votre adresse sur notre le travail sont
disponibles sans trop d'effort si à peu
près chacun d'entre nous
donc alors le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui le principe qui prévaut
c'est de collecter les données d'abord
et puis de se demander ce qu'on va faire
avec
ensuite à mon sens il faudrait qu'on
change de paradigme et qu'on aille vers
un modèle où les preuves les données de
chaque individu son protégé et
inaccessible par défaut et où divers
mécanismes obligerait les compagnies a
demandé à utiliser nos données
uniquement dans des buts précis est
clairement spécifié
alors là cette prolifération de capteurs
tout autour de nous pousse par exemple
au groupe de recherche aujourd'hui à
revoir nos algorithmes de traitement de
données pour contrôler précisément la
quantité d'informations personnelles et
individualisé qui l'utilisent et avec de
tels ragots rythme on peut envisager
on peut imaginer un modèle à nouveau
modèle économique où vous redevenez
vraiment propriétaire de vos données et
ou pour prendre juste un exemple vous
pourriez être récompensés financièrement
ou par une meilleure qualité de service
en fonction de la quantité
d'informations personnelles que vous
êtes prêts à fournir à une application
enfin dernier défi que je mentionnerai
pour aujourd'hui la complexité
intrinsèque des systèmes qu'on cherche à
contrôler et qui se manifeste qui est
liée à la taille de ces systèmes et à la
présence de la composante humaine je
vous rappelle que nous sommes dans le
système à contrôler alors le fait est
que nous sommes beaucoup plus difficile
à modéliser beaucoup plus imprévisible
que le moteur de la machine de watt et
en particulier à l inverse des machines
nous agissons librement et généralement
pour maximiser notre bien-être personnel
et pas nécessairement celui du groupe
dans son ensemble comme cherchent à le
faire le contrôleur donc une suspicion
de fondamentales qui se posent
automaticien aujourd'hui comme moi qui
s'intéressent à la commande des goûters
grands systèmes complexes
c'est de savoir comment modéliser
implémenter et anticiper l'impact qu'une
stratégie de commandes aura sur une
infrastructure complexe comme le réseau
routier avec laquelle une foule de gens
interagissent
alors pour céder une source
d'inspiration vient en fait de la
biologie
où on trouve de grands systèmes
complexes formé d'individus chacun
égoïste mais qui en groupe sont tout de
même capables de former des structures
macroscopique remarquable alors inspiré
par ces phénomènes il ya une dizaine
d'années des collègues automaticien de
polytechnique et de l'université mcgill
ont développé une nouvelle théorie qu'on
appelle théorie des jeux a chois moyens
qui s'intéresse en premier lieu à l'état
et aux mouvements macroscopique d'un
groupe comme ce cône ici qui est
beaucoup plus prévisible que le
mouvement aléatoire de chaque individu
alors dans notre exemple de trafic cet
état macroscopique qu'on appelle aussi
chant moyens et simplement la densité de
voitures sur chaque route
ensuite on postule que chaque individu
va optimiser son comportement par
rapport à ce chant moyens donc dans
notre exemple chacun va essayer d'éviter
la congestion pour minimiser son temps
de parcours
enfin et c'est là une étape assez
délicate du du raisonnement et je vous
laisserai y réfléchir si c'est pas clair
pendant la journée
alors il faut remarquer que ce chant
moyen est lui même simplement issus des
actions individuelles et donc il y à une
condition spécifique qu'il doit remplir
pour qu'un certain étape macroscopique
soit réalisable
il faut en fait que cet état major pour
que cet état macroscopique soit
réalisable il faut en fait qu'il soit
collectivement reproduit lorsque chaque
individu qu'ils anticipent se positionne
optimalement par rapport à lui c'est un
peu philosophique mais bref tout ce que
vous pouvez peut-être retenir c'est que
en mettant ce genre de raisonnement en
équation on peut prévoir les quelques
évolutions possibles qui sont les seuls
les blés seule raisonnable pour le
groupe est aussi concevoir des méthodes
de commandes qui cherche à pousser
l'état collectif dans un état désirable
tout en laissant aux individus le soin
d'implémenter cet état localement en
optimisant leur comportement comme
d'habitude donc
plus de capteurs et d'objets connectés
ouvre la voie des systèmes automatisés à
grande échelle qui nous permettront
comme dans notre exemple on l'espère de
nous déplacer plus efficacement mais
aussi de mieux gérer nos ressources nos
industries et nous faciliterons un aux
tâches quotidiennes
en même temps il nous reste beaucoup de
travail à accomplir et de recherche à
mener aujourd'hui quand vous entendez
parler de l'internet des objets c'est
surtout l'infrastructure qui supportera
ses services qui est en train d'être
mise en place
l'intelligence qu'il faut développer sur
cette infrastructure elle en est à ses
tout débuts
et pour qu'elle se développe de manière
socialement acceptable et qu'elle
représente un véritable progrès il faut
que les applications qui touche le monde
physique continue à être développés avec
un niveau de fiabilité adéquat qu'elle
prenne en compte la complexité et la
richesse des interactions sociales et
surtout qu'elles préservent notre droit
fondamental à la confidentialité